I wonder if we could start with Ukraine
um is this the de facto invasion we're
waking up to a very dark day in Europe
and it's clear from what we've already
seen and and found out today that the
Russians President Putin has decided to
to attack the sovereignty of Ukraine and
his territorial Integrity we've always
said that's completely unacceptable
we've seen that he has recognized these
Breakaway Eastern regions in Ukraine and
from the reports or I think we can
already tell that he's sent in tanks and
troops and so I think it's it from that
you can conclude that the invasion of
Ukraine has begun what are we going to
do about it there's a cobra meeting and
taking place right now chaired by the
Prime Minister and of course that will
be discussing what action we will take
we have been very clear right from the
start of this crisis that we wouldn't
hesitate to take action I understand
that the Prime Minister spoke to
president zielinski of Ukraine last
night assured him of our support but
also that we will be introducing
sanctions as we said we always will what
sort of Military Support can we offer
we've already been providing Military
Support to Ukraine now for a number of
months and and certainly that's picked
up in the last few weeks I'm sure that
will be part of the discussion at the
Cobra meeting and we will continue to
provide such support but also look at
how we can take action against Russia
through sanctions and and there are
measures that that can be taken because
of legislation that we had introduced
last year that will help in in
responding and responding very quickly
and I'm sure that we make those
sanctions targeted as possible to the
people that are responsible for this
fragrant violation of international law
I got the impression that there were
sort of two tiers of economic sanctions
why are we are we still going to do that
and or are we just going to hit him hard
well I I think I'd want to wait for the
outcome of the Cobra meeting I think
that is that is appropriate and I know
the after that meeting has concluded the
Prime Minister will make a statement to
Parliament and set out what we know
about the current situation on the
ground but also what action we will take
the Weaponry at the moment is defensive
are we going to send offensive weaponry
again I think that these will be exactly
the things that are rightly discussed in
the Cobra meeting where the ministers at
that meeting will be presented with all
the latest information intelligence
including uh farmer our allies across
NATO and once that meeting has concluded
I think it is right that the Prime
Minister sets out the action to
Parliament first just another question
on that then we'll move on to kovid if I
may what should Brits do that are in
these two Breakaway regions at the
moment well we've already advised
British citizens uh to to leave Ukraine
and and I hope that all British citizens
have been following that advice of
course not everyone does my
understanding is that they are still
commercial flights available people are
still able to leave Ukraine and we would
continue to advise those individuals
British citizens to leave Ukraine so get
out if you can yes
um and just a final thought on that if I
may there was a statement overnight from
the White House talking about basically
a communique between the United States
and France and Germany and a couple of
times referring to those three nations
why are we not included in that well I
haven't seen the particular communique
that you refer to but you can see I
think everyone has been evident over the
last few weeks how important a role the
UK has played in in this crisis working
with our allies across NATO uh when the
conversations the Prime Minister himself
has been having with the presidents and
leaders of different countries within
NATO and also what the Prime Minister
had to say himself at the recent Munich
conference something that will very much
be troubling my viewers this morning and
I know you'll want to clear up all
restrictions drops as far as covert is
concerned from Thursday how are we going
to Future proof against variants look so
yesterday it was was a historic day we
were already the freest country in
Europe and yesterday we were able to go
further thanks to the protections we've
built but also the efforts of the
British people and I think it's worth
remembering that the the restrictions
that we had introduced of course they
had an important purpose but they were
never intended to become a way of life
you know they also came with huge costs
for our freedoms education mental health
and other significant costs so you're
being able to remove them in the way
that we did yesterday was a significant
you know step forward but of course we
do need to remain Vigilant so that means
we keep a hold of our primary defenses
especially uh vaccines if we look at the
last few months I think the one thing if
we have to make just one thing that made
the biggest difference of all was our
booster program we were the first
country in Europe to to be able to boost
50 of our adult population now it's over
70 percent and that's also by the way
one of the reasons I accepted the advice
of the jcvi yesterday to offer a second
booster in the spring to those aged over
75 elderly people in care homes in in
September for over 50s is that right
well there maybe I mean what the jcbi
said yesterday that is their current
view but of course they will keep that
under review but there may well be I
think it's likely there will be one in
the winter but we uh we can't say at
this point for what age group that will
be in again we will listen to the jcbi
at that time but certainly for the
spring there will be one for the group
of people that the jcbi set out in terms
of your particular question though about
um future yeah yeah and that's and and
that is it is right we have to
understand that clearly your covert is
still out there we may be done with
covid but it's certainly not done with
us and we have to remain cautious and
Vigilant and that is why we set out
yesterday also just how we will continue
to do that so vaccines remain an
important part of our defenses the
antivirals and other treatments that we
have also uh will play a continued
important role but also we've put in
place a surveillance system that we're
able to detect any potential future
threads and also the ability for us to
react quickly should that happen great
way to do that would be to keep lateral
flow tests you're not going to do that
we understand that it's going to cost
something like two billion pounds a
month as soon as like an awful lot of
money um should we have free covid tests
lateral flow test for some groups we
will be keeping freelateral tests for
some groups though for the most
vulnerable so so for example I mentioned
a moment ago we have antiviral so these
are fantastic new drugs specifically
designed for covert they played a huge
role of Omicron and they will continue
to play an important role so for people
that are eligible for those drugs we've
targeted those at the what we call the
clinically extremely vulnerable as
defined by the NHS it's about it's about
1.3 million people and for them with its
pcrs or any other testing that we
require to to make sure that we know
when we need to offer those drugs to
protect them those we have testing in
place we will have lateral flow tests
for staff in in for the time being we
will keep for staff in Care Homes and we
know when we will we will keep it under
review so that is the the decisions we
announced yesterday for certain
vulnerable settings essentially your
care homes and hospitals to lateral flow
tests and PCR tests in some cases will
continue to be used but to all intents
and purposes people won't know if
they've got covered or not will they
from the first of April
um they won't they won't without a test
of course you won't know and but that
this is you could go to work with covert
well you you could go to work with flu
and when we and the reason I say that is
that one of the things that the Prime
Minister rightly said yesterday is we've
got to learn to live with covid as we
have learned to live with other
respiratory diseases you know if someone
thinks that they might have flu they
don't need to take a test you know you
just you recognize the symptoms and
ideally you would you stay away from
work you don't want to infect your
colleagues or friends and and that is
how we have lives with viruses and now
with with covid obviously we couldn't
have done anything like that at the
start of code for and throughout most of
the pandemic because we didn't have the
tools that we have today but the
situation today is very different yeah
but the Prime Minister should say that
we need to have the German attitude of
calling in sick which basically is if
you're unwell you should call in sick
the Germans um they apparently the sick
pay is 50 pay for 84 weeks ours is 96
pounds 35 Pence you can see why people
go to work even when they're feeling
unwell we
you're referring to our statutory sick
pay levels you know fairly most
businesses you know most employers pay a
lot more than that I mean that is a a
minimum
you're right that's why I said I
recognize that and that's why I said
most I didn't say yeah but it doesn't
and workers in a very difficult it is
important to keep new levels of
statutory sick pay and other benefits uh
to keep that uh under review and that is
done at all times but it is also right
that we start moving back to normal and
and I think this is a moment you know
what the government announced yesterday
it's a moment that we can all be proud
of as we've all we've played a
collective effort uh to to reach this
point
that's my point so if you are at work
and you and a colleague test positive or
you fear that they have got covered is
it reasonable for you to tell your boss
that you're going to go home
is it I think if you yes I think if you
if you feel that you got covered uh just
as if you feel you've got flu or some
other virus that you shouldn't really be
at work of course it's reasonable to say
to your boss that it might not be
sensible for those employers who think
that that's a bad idea who wouldn't
support that you're saying actually you
need to bear in mind how your workers
might feel yes what we will be setting
out is is guidance your public health
guidance so for now whilst we're
removing the legal requirement to
self-isolate from Thursday uh that there
will be guidance that would advise you
to continue to do so until the end of
March and from the 1st of April we will
set out new guidance that will be much
more General but still sensor will guide
us about how you might behave if you
believe that you have some kind of
respiratory or other disease okay two
acronym questions before I let you go
are these passenger locator forms bane
of Travelers lives given that you don't
have to self-isolate from Thursday if
you do have covered we're going to get
rid of them
um well I wouldn't go quite as far right
now I'd say we'll get rid of them right
away but I do think now with the
measures that we've announced yesterday
uh there is a case to review them and
that review is being done right now with
the transport secretary and the home
office and I'm sure some progress will
be made and fixed penalty notices
um are you with the James cleverley
School of thinking which is doesn't
matter if the Prime Minister has broken
the law or not he should continue on
look I'm not going to get into this
we've discussed this so many times okay
and I think but you never answered and
the reason is that there are authorities
official authorities that are looking
into into this whole issue rightly so
and and the Prime Minister himself has
come to Parliament and apologized and
set out what's happening but also he's
rightly not getting involved in what the
authority is doing let's let we should
we'll let the authorities do their work
I don't think it's appropriate to get
into if it's misled Parliament should he
resign well it's as I said before these
are you when you ask me questions with
if and if this that these are
hypothetical questions I know you Define
hypothetical for me before yes I do but
that doesn't change it I'm glad that
stayed with you so I'm I've taken that
away uh but uh I'm not gonna get into
this this is the the focus on what's
actually with regard to this the premise
has come to Parliament authorities
investigating this but I'm focused on my
day-to-day job